God help this country we cannot take
four more years of that anyway all this
after Biden took last night off to
prepare for today's big event now he was
a no-show at last night's dinner with
our NATO allies so does any of this
Inspire confidence of course not and
neither does the leadership of Biden's
Democratic Pals out in California get
this estate assembly out there in
California panel just block passage of a
bill that would have increased the
penalties for repeat try a child sex
offenders repeat offenders here with
reaction the governor of a state where
Common Sense uh matters Christie gnome
of the great state of South Dakota how
are you governor
I find that humiliating for our country
I can't help it I love America and and
to see this embarrassment day in and day
out I find it hard to watch
it makes me nervous I watch these
Summits and I look at uh Biden up there
and I I get nervous because I realize
how powerful it is to have the president
of the United States up there and what a
picture it sends to the world of the
strength of our country and then he can
barely get through a sentence he can
find barely find his way off stage I'm
surprised zelinski helped him off the
stage frankly and it just is you know an
example over and over again of the ways
that this Administration is failing and
we we're failing at even the basic you
know what it takes to be president and
that stand up be strong on a world stage
lead the world in peace and and strength
and he just can't do it Governor you're
a mom uh what would your reaction be if
people in your state uh
would were blocking passage of a bill
that would increase the penalties for
repeat child trafficking offenders what
would your reaction as a mom be never
mind governor
yeah no I'm I'm horrified by this I
can't believe it I am a mom I'm also a
grandma of two little kiddos and I can't
believe that uh this would happen that
leaders would say these traffickers
deserve a pass they should be punished
to the highest extent of the law and
never be allowed to see Freedom again
because of what they do to the poor and
the innocent children that are subjected
to their kind of work so now what goes
on in California every day blows my mind
I feel like it's another world that
operates out there in another mindset
I'm so grateful that South Dakota isn't
like that and that we have people that
still love each other take care of each
other understand personal responsibility
and they make wise decisions and uphold
the law Governor let me ask you you
recently started a campaign to bring
jobs to the state of South Dakota part
of it includes people that say nurses or
doctors that have licenses that they
would be transferable to your state but
more importantly you talked about having
the lowest unemployment in the the
country of any state and you are looking
for people to be employed there and you
have an apprentice program correctly if
I'm wrong that starts people out at over
eighty thousand dollars a year
yes we did we started to recruit people
to a state of South Dakota we have the
lowest unemployment rate in the history
of the nation we also have the fastest
growing incomes over the last five to
ten year period people here are doing
well we need more workers to fill our
jobs we've got businesses expanding
people moving here and we've already
seen this marketing campaign become the
most successful marketing campaign that
our state has ever tackled before we've
had thousands of people respond the
number one state they're moving here
from is California after that it's
Florida Texas Arizona New York we're
thrilled that people want to come to
South Dakota and be a part of our way of
life and they're coming here for Freedom
so here they can keep more money in
their pockets they can make a high
income pursue their dreams and they can
make the best decisions for their
families it really is a story that I
think our country needs to hear right
now Sean we need to talk again about the
value of a work ethic what a work ethic
does for you the value of a job we were
created to serve each other and when we
do that we're happier we're better off
spiritually mentally it really is
something that America needs that vision
of Hope again I think that's well said I
think we are here and designed to serve
other people in whatever capacity we all
have talent from God
um last question you probably won't like
me asking it I've got to believe that it
in this presidential race when we get a
nominee that you'll be on any candidate
shortlist would you consider being vice
president of the Republican candidate
for president asked you
you know we'll see I'm focused on South
Dakota I do think we need a Republican
president I think we need the best
Republican president we need the best
person that understands this job will go
out and fight for the American people
every single day and not quit so we need
our policies back that bring Prosperity
back and deal with protecting our
national security my biggest challenge
every single day is what China is doing
to my state in this country will fight
to defend it all right Governor great to
have you congratulations on that
successful program hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else